ne cherchez pas le sentier qui mène au
lieu d'images il est fermé depuis le
cyclone Dina d'ailleurs de ce village il
ne reste rien
seul le cirque a conserver son nom
mais ce nom d'où vient-il
pourquoi ça s'appelle ma
fatigue
c'était le nom de d'une personne et
également d'un village il y avait des
magasins chinois ça a été recouvert par
un éboulis
en malgache
signifie pas de la marche d'accès qu'il
s'agit mais d'une ancienne source
au milieu du 19e siècle un sorcier
l'aurait baptisé ainsi en raison des
vertus mystérieuses voire maléfiques de
ses eaux riches en souffre et en sodium
les esclaves marrons de l'époque la
connaissaient bien mais ce n'est qu'en
1853 qu'elle fut officiellement reconnue
on construisit alors le chemin
départemental numéro 2 ainsi qu'un
village thermal situé un peu en amont de
la ravine cimandale
quelques années plus tard le village
avait prospéré et comptait 32 familles
plus réputé alors que les sources d'elle
bourre ou de Cilaos ont venait à ma fate
pour soigner l'herpès l'arthrose
l'eczéma l'asthme la bronchite la
laryngite bref toutes sortes
d'affections y compris le paludisme ou
la tuberculose
mais cette source miraculeuse était la
proie des crues à chaque intempéries en
1913 l'effondrement d'un pan du
Bronchard obstrua le cours du ciment
d'ail la brusque montée des eaux emporta
le village sans faire de victimes
mais la source fut ensevelie sous plus
de 300 mètres de roche et de terre sous
laquelle elle est encore aujourd'hui